Vilhelm Hohenzollern the former kaiser
wilhelm ii died in the netherlands in
1941 he had abdicated the throne in 1918
just prior to the end of the First World
War and fled from Belgium which raises
the question what was he doing during
those 21 years why did he pick the
Netherlands to flee - and how did he
feel about Germany during his time there
well to answer the first question the
reason why though he'll pick the
Netherland was simple he couldn't go
anywhere else since Germany was in late
1918 falling apart with socialist
revolution military revolts and popular
discontent gripping the country his
abdication had happened in the town of
spar in Belgium and so he had few
options travelled to the west and hand
himself over to the Allies who likely
weren't going to be too kind to him
travel to another country via Germany
and risk captured by the discontented
groups there or trouble north to the
Netherlands and hope that that worked
out and of course he opted for the
latter which was quite the surprise for
the sole dutch soldier who was working
that particular border crossing after
much deliberation the Dutch granted him
access the former Kaiser then spent some
months armored wrong and when I think
really happened providing you ignore the
time when US Army Colonel and former
Tennessee senator Luke lair attempted to
kidnap him in early 1919 it wasn't a
very good attempt though he and some of
the US soldiers went to a morong and
claiming to be diplomats who wanted to
speak to the former Kaiser though ham
said no and so they left with all that
drama out the way the Kaiser soon
purchased a villa at dawn most
importantly not knowing what was going
to happen to him you see the on Tom were
putting a great deal of pressure on the
Netherlands to extradite the former
Kaiser to stand trial the Dutch said no
because they were a sovereign nation
which had opted to grant him asylum and
they didn't want to diminish that in the
end allied disagreements more pressing
international matters and simply time
meant that the cause fulfill hams
extradition simply petered out after
this Vilhelm settled into his new life
in the Netherlands and it wasn't long
after that that his wife the former
Empress or Guster
died he got married again shortly
afterwards and took to justifying his
previous actions as German Kaiser he
spent the next decade and a half
decrying the new Vimal Republic and
blaming weak ministers and the Jews for
his downfall
he was also patiently waiting for the
day that the German people would
inevitably realize this and invite him
back to rule again Wilhelm maintained
conservative and monarchist contacts in
Germany throughout the 1920s most of
whom like the National Socialists in
their mustachioed leader he didn't care
for his attitude towards them softened
in the early 1930s when they started to
win many votes and vilhelm up with
Hermann Goering twice to discuss the
idea of restoration but of course Hitler
wasn't interested in sharing power or
restoring the monarchy which is why
after he secured power he banned all
monarchist societies at this point it
became pretty clear that vilhelm wasn't
going to get his throne back and his
hatred for Hitler grew and grew the
feeling was mutual and the Nazi Party
outlawed any monarchy symbols and Hitler
publicly decried the old monarchy as
having brought Germany to ruin not
because Vilhelm shouldn't have started
the war in the first place but because
Hitler thought that he should have
refused to surrender under any
circumstances this mutual disdain
continued up until the annexation of
Austria which the Kaiser approved of in
the conquest of Poland when in 1940 the
Netherlands was invaded by the ver
marked bill hem was left well alone and
no one from the German military bothered
him he have actually been offered asylum
in Britain by Winston Churchill but he
refused to accept it preferring to
remain in his new home and accept his
fate their fill home also congratulated
Hitler after the fall of France
something which he considered to be
revenged for 1918 Kaiser Wilhelm was
getting old at this point and was
becoming unwell he died in 1941 and
Hitler first wanted him to be returned
to Germany to be buried in a ceremony
which implied that Hitler had been
appointed his successor
although Vilhelm had written in his
world that he did not wish to be buried
in Germany until the monarchy had been
restored there which interestingly is
something that the Nazis respected and
he was buried as his home in Dorne
ultimately Vilhelm would never get the
record to the throne that he always
believed he would monarchism in Germany
never recovered after the mid 1930s and
vilhelm spent the last decades of his
life in semi seclusion not as a member
of royalty but simply as mr.
Hohenzollern I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching with
extra thanks to these patrons you can
see on screen for their continued
support and an extra special thanks to
James Bissonnette David archaeologists
as ARCA Flash Danny Maloney party-boy
Koch coolin Castleman Rob Waterhouse
Chris wicker Gustav Swan David Silverman
Winston Kate woods Christian checky
Maggie packs Kowski Lexi Schwinn Anthony
Beckett Robert Wetzel Skye Chappell Icke
spinning three plates are on the white
and Michael Reynolds